Microsoft's Windows 10 news event has  wrapped and there are some great new  features on the way to the gaming world  I'm Tony and this GameSpot news update  is for the PC crowd the next change  coming to Windows 10 is called the  creators update and it will offer native  support for game broadcasting earlier  this year Microsoft purchased streaming  service beam and that technology is  baked into the creators update letting  anyone easily stream from their Windows  10 computer  additionally the arena feature is coming  to the Xbox app which will let you  create video game tournaments with  friends the creators update is coming in  spring 2017 and it'll be totally free  microsoft has said that there are  currently 400 million devices running  Windows 10 so expect a ton of new  streamers to emerge thanks to beam and  if you want to keep up with all the  latest on Microsoft PC or video games in  general you're already in the right  place